okay I told you I guess it was last week
or maybe the week before that Steven
Bannon is out of Donald Trump's
administration probably related to the
bringing in of the new chief of staff
John Calley who does not seem to take
too kindly to the riffraff and
extremists to some degree that were in
the Trump administration Bannon was of
course one of the most vile influences
truly depraved that Stephan ban and
Breitbart propagandist was even allowed
within a mile of the Oval Office but he
was actually kind of sickens me to say
it one of the closest advisors to the
President of the United States for about
seven months and the question when
Bannon was booted was would he begin to
publicly criticize Donald Trump's
actions or statements or decisions or
positions and he did his first major TV
interview since leaving the White House
with Charlie Rose over the weekend and
in an online segment of 60 minutes
Bannon singled out and he said when
Donald Trump fired James Comey back in
the first half of May of this year that
was the biggest mistake in modern
political history what we are learning
more about is that most of Donald
Trump's decisions they didn't come out
of nowhere right in other words someone
in Donald Trump's staff was typically
involved in whatever weird decision
Donald Trump decided to make but there's
not really a consensus so for example
last week I told you we learned that
when Donald Trump decided to fire James
Comey he put together this bizarre
letter with the help of adviser Steven
Miller and one other person I don't have
been Jared Kushner don't remember who
but then he went to other people
including vice president Mike Pence we
learned last week and people were
surprised by this decision and surprised
by the letter and surprised by the
reasoning and this proves the point that
I've been making for a while which is
that we can't look at anything Trump
does and say oh let's analyze it to
figure out what it says about the
president's philosophy on a particular
area of politics or whatever
Trump's decisions and actions are
representative only of what Trump and
one or two or maybe three other people
came up with that day or the day before
and it sounded good at the time and
Trump did it period it's not
representative of
any broader strategy and that's what
we're learning from what we learned
about the Steven Miller Comey firing
letter from what we're learning about
what Steve Bannon is saying here that
clearly it's just hey here's two people
I found who gave me this idea and I'm
going to do it even though 98% of my
administration doesn't even have a clue
to what's going on
interestingly enough though Steve Bannon
during this interview declined to say
whether or not Jared Kushner had
anything to do with the fire yeah and
it's not like he was you know laying low
during this entire interview he was
throwing quite a few bombshells and you
remember him and Jared Kushner had quite
a beef going on during at the time that
they both worked in the administration
so it's interesting to see why he
wouldn't speak on that I I don't know
the answer and that was noticeable to me
as well and that doesn't mean everything
Bannon said during this interview was
wrong including that if Comey hadn't
been fired Bannon said we might never
have gotten the Robert Muller special
prosecutor appointment and that's true I
mean recalled that part of why Trump
fired Comey was to stifle the Trump
Russia investigation and it actually did
the opposite and it goes to another
storyline I've been talking about with
you which is that much of what's going
on with the Trump Russia scandal is
totally self-inflicted
if Trump had been quiet all along other
than to simply say I support the
investigation I'm cooperating with it we
will work on our agenda and the
investigation will ultimately clear us
of wrongdoing if we if we eliminate
Twitter and the conflicting statements
from different people about Trump and
all that stuff you have a trump Russia
investigation that's only a tiny
fraction of what we have and bannon's
not stupid he predicted Trump's move on
daca would split the Republican Party
even more I think that that's true but
Steve Bannon still did say to Charlie
Rose that he supports Trump which is
interesting if this is if this is
abandon that supports Trump I don't even
want to know or maybe I do actually
what abandon that doesn't support Trump
would look like it's interesting that
Steve Bannon is saying though that it
was such a major political mistake to
fire James Comey because on the other
side he also thinks that this whole
Russia story is a total and complete
farce
he said that main interview two so then
he's making a case that it's entirely
based on optics that it was a bad
decision to final call me that's one
possibility he also could be saying that
if they had not escalated the entire
thing with the firing that there
wouldn't really have been any evidence
tying them to actual collusion but that
now
there's a broader investigation that has
opened up Donald Trump to all other
sorts of investigation
that's what might ultimately be his
undoing I don't know especially now that
Robert Miller is looking into Trump's
personal finance person organization
that can't be good that maybe that's
what he meant
oh really knows right we we may never
know what Steve Mann had been and really
meant the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad